as a party people need to understand
there's Republican Party that brought
the blacks out of slavery the first time
and it will be the Republican Party that
brings them out of slavery from the
Democratic Party this time after Mitt
Romney lost the presidential race in
2012 Republicans commissioned an autopsy
report to figure out what went wrong and
how to win next time some of the biggest
takeaways were pass comprehensive
immigration reform listen to minorities
move left's on LGBT issues and don't
just be the party of rich guys and now
they got Donald Trump
we've got Governor Susana Martinez we've
got Indian Governor nikki Haley of South
Carroll that doesn't reflect that
electorate I'm sorry what when you look
at the black situation okay we as a
party we are that what you're trying to
make the premise that we're failing with
the black community and we're not the
party that's murdering 58 million babies
in this country through the primarily
primary focus on the black Hispanic and
low-income that's not the Republican
Party that's a democratic holiday my
turn
it's called Planned Parenthood another
thing the reports that is that if Latino
is in this country for see the candidate
or not
to not want them to be unwelcoming of
them in the country they're not gonna
listen to the next thing that comes out
of their mouth
so did Donald turn shoot himself in the
foot and lose the Hispanic vote I live
from in El Paso Texas at the border city
heavily Hispanic population and you'd be
surprised how many Hispanics actually
sit there and support the things that
mr. Trump is saying as far as securing
the border and stopping the illegals
folks gonna look at myself and I'm a
immigrant from Taiwan and I was able to
go through the Republican range and be
elected the National Kamini woman's for
Kansas so I don't know we're really
anti-immigrant we just anti-illegal
immigrant to everyone out there who says
the Republican Party is just super white
and super out of touch what are you
saying well that couldn't be less so if
you sit there and you look at the
there's quite a quite a few folks of
many different
Republican presidential candidates
historically lose to women women's vote
and you know Donald Trump unfortunately
polls show that he loses it by double
digits so obviously that's a problem
during you know we have to as a party
reach out to younger people and
minorities to remain relevant you know
the party's not going to be able to
survive in the future with people like
me that's just what the report it said
but it looks like the GOP is headed in a
different direction I guess we'll find
out in November